I have a rare genetic condition called  XP which means I can't go off the Sun  it's not gonna fall into remission and  every year the risk becomes more serious  so I'm stuck inside all day what should  I have said hey I watched outside my  window for the past 10 years now I've  been stalking you Charlie okay you would  want to do something sometime would you  I'm really busy during the day but make  you pay for your night what does Katie  Price want to do there's so many things  I wanna do  I am not comfortable with him not  knowing I just need a little longer  being someone more than just a disease  this isn't something you can just not  tell me I'm so sorry  kitty we're not the couple who doesn't  try  having someone the best part  [Music]  you